if you're like most people you're
probably cutting your onion all wrong hi
I'm Julia Colin Davidson from America's
Test Kitchen and this is the proper way
to cut an onion now first thing you want
to put on some onion goggles I know they
look kind of silly but they work like a
charm but first we're gonna cut off the
tip of the onion and place the onion on
that flat spot so it doesn't roll around
cut the onion into quarters through the
root end making sure there's a little
bit of the root end on each of the cores
because that holds the onion together as
you cut it now satisfying part you peel
the onion after you've corded it because
it's so much easier than trying to peel
a whole onion all right now here's the
trick taking your knife you want to cut
through the onion towards the root end
but not all the way through you want to
leave all those layers intact once you
do One Direction tip the onion on the
other side and do it again all right
once you've done all that turn the onion
sideways and then slice right down into
nice fine dice now if any little pieces
fall off just set them aside and when
you're all done Cobble those together
and give them all a wipe through with a
knife and that's it easy onion cutting